yo tell me this man let's say we fast
forward 10 years from now where you hope
to be at
um [__]
the Grammys you might get the hey you go
listen you might you're gonna get you're
gonna be in the Grammy sooner sooner
than that right yeah
you state you still see yourself making
music in a decade
like you and I keep doing this [__] like
just as long as it makes as long as I
can yeah yeah as long as it makes sense
as long as they're [__] with you
you're still gonna do it yeah because we
just saw like [__] I think Snoop just I
mean snoops in his 50s Dr Dre's in his
50s like Hove is up there like Nas Nas
and nausea you [__] us
you uh who's your who's your goats like
give me your like top three or four of
all time
MCs
top three
Tupac Lil Wayne
uh two by the way I'm trying to think
foreign
[Music]
that's the two
and I like it it's what I'm listening to
I just wanted you just like how I see it
who you think is the goat yes
[Music]
I like damn it so DMX incredible damn is
shout out to [__] Wayne though Wayne
with the one are you excited to watch
him he's on uh he's supposed to be
co-hosting with Skip Bayless now on Fox
so Shannon sharp left and now little
Wayne is going to be skip bayless's new
co-host on Fridays they're gonna be huh
that [__] should be crazy I ain't gonna
watch what
apparently he's into sports so I mean
[__] he's gonna have to be you don't
have to why ain't you be at everything
about the boxing [__] he'd be everywhere
what's been have you have you been in
the big fight chat yeah I've been in the
fights I've been alive
Wednesday you went to the tank Davis to
Ryan Garcia one went down
uh the Charlotte one Charlotte twin I
heard the tank Davis fight the
atmosphere was insane yeah that like the
best I hadn't been somewhere I heard the
boxer yeah it's better than everything I
heard people say football NBA what a big
fight it's got like a super field like
you at the like that you yelling like
you're the center of the world yeah
you ever see your big boxing fan yeah
did you watch uh what's his face the
Logan not Logan Paul Jake Paul yeah you
find ideas yeah I've seen that I mean
that was kind of I feel like if they
would have been some information and
ideas would have [__] him up for real
yeah but I knew Nate I knew he was going
to be an idea but I knew they did we're
gonna quit yeah he don't quit then when
he lose he at like he won so he ain't
really lost
UFC is the best what about wrestling you
ever watch wrestling I used to back in
the day who was your guy
um oh yeah in the Rock that's the
funniest thing that's the attitude
everybody uh
yeah you should and then he was also
Dude Love do you remember that man yeah
he was two people who loved he was the
hippie dude yeah shout out to Mick Foley
he's a legend bro what the other man I
used to hate that name
Vince McMahon yeah yeah oh yeah Vince
McMahon's a wild boy he's also a
billionaire
yo you should go to WrestleMania it will
it's not like going to the fight I'm
sure you did yeah the one here I don't
know I was young
WrestleMania is crazy
yeah that's like that feels like you're
at some like
big time like it's almost like you're at
the Super Bowl but it's wrestling I
don't I can't remember
so you went as a kid yeah
I went to Hulk Hogan's uh he has a
restaurant in Tampa terrible food but
nice guy yeah yeah Hulk Hogan is I don't
know if he's the goat he
he put it on yeah like that for sure he
also
there's been some uh some some audio of
him being kind of racist before Oh you
guys I mean he said some [__] that was
kind of wild you know what I'm saying I
never heard they canceled they so he got
in trouble and they deleted all his
matches off of the WWE Network for like
a year
and then they brought him back because
it's like if you're the WWE like you're
really gonna ban Hulk Hogan for life
right he apologized obviously but yeah
Hulk Hogan you know shout out to Hulk
man yeah